[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the i
economist ian
and the telegraph's assistant comment
editor olivia utley great to see both of
you staying with us right through until
just before midnight so to the front
pages let's take a look shall we
starting with the financial times which
leads with the us government's banning
of russian oil imports and also mentions
the uk's decision to do the same
the guardian calls that news
a blow to putin
the metro reacting to the speech given
to the house of commons by the ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky with the
headline hear hear hero
the eye quoting from that address we
will fight in the forests and on the
streets
that is also the main story for the mail
same headline we will fight until the
end they say
and the mirror too we will never
surrender
the telegraph leads with the offer from
poland to help ukraine with mig fighters
to tackle the russian assault from the
air
while the star has an interview with
ukrainian former boxing star vladimir
klitschko on the front line defending
his country in what he calls the biggest
fight of his life
while the sun has the story of an
unnamed 19 year old coldstream guardsman
who the paper is choosing not to name
but has reportedly gone awol in order to
fight in ukraine
well a quick reminder that by scanning
the qr code you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out those
front pages
while you watch us so let's return them
to our guests
for now uh joined by ian and olivia
arkley welcome to both of you um so
should we start with the uh this
historic occasion ian of the president
of ukraine uh addressing the house of
commons to uh to multiple rounds of
applause
yeah standing ovation at the start
standing ovation at the end as we would
expect given the same was hanged out to
the ukrainian ambassador rita recently
um this is the third
sort of major i suppose foreign speech
that he's done by zoom you've done one
in the u.s
one to europe he's now done one here
it's quite hard i think when you're i
mean the way that we were forced to
watch it and the way the mps were forced
to watch it is of course with his voice
being sort of dubbed over um by someone
translating it and that takes away quite
a lot of the strength
of the manner in which he speaks this
sort of softly spoken kind of almost for
eternal leadership quality that he emits
so you don't quite get the full sort of
strength of his manner of his charisma
and of the things that he manages to
communicate very effectively when
listening to it that way but even then
you saw the intelligence of the speech
you saw the emotional intelligence as
well as the political intelligence of
sort of echoing churchill's fight them
on the beaches speech uh for for the
british parliament it was still good
strong rousing stuff yes and that's
certainly been picked up by the eye
we will fight in the forests and on the
streets on the shores we will not lose
that chichilian element of it he he knew
his audience and the audience was
receptive wasn't it olivia
absolutely um and i think what ian was
saying there about the emotional
intelligence is very important and you
know it's sometimes easy to forget
although we have heard it a lot in
recent days that zelansky is such an
unusual figure the way he rose through
politics is unique he was an actor who
played a president uh in a in a drama
and then became the president himself um
and
he wasn't really considered a serious
figure but actually the sort of charisma
that you get as an actor that emotional
intelligence that the way the way he
communicates with people the way he's
got the people behind him is exactly
what ukraine needs in in this
hour of need um so they've got the sort
of perfect president for the hour
meanwhile um economically a really big
news day let's go to the guardian one of
a number of newspapers that's decided to
lead on uh the hydrocarbons which is the
way the prime minister sometimes chooses
to describe the uh
the the parts what that we buy in from
russia the oil the gas and so on
and some big again unified decisions
from various nations including the us
the uk and the european union which
significantly has decided to cut back
two-thirds of its reliance on russian
gas by the end of this year which will
be you know very difficult to stomach
for some nations in
extremely difficult this is actually
quite
quite a dangerous area that we're
stepping into in terms of the unity of
the western response right like i mean
we looked last week
look at the moves for instance to
basically freeze russia's foreign
reserves now one of the reasons i mean
that was i mean the most significant act
of economic warfare that we've seen in
our lifetime against the major economy
we've seen similar against iran but
against the major economy we haven't
seen anything like that before
now that was possible partly because
they sidestepped the energy issue you
know the us is not relying on russian
energy the uk is not reliant i mean
small amounts but nothing that it can't
live without europe is i mean different
countries different degrees but europe
is so the second you start talking about
energy you run that risk of the fracture
in the western alliance and also we're
forcing the eu into a position where it
has to maintain its internal coherence
and its response now in a slightly
divergent way we're moving that way
really tough talk from the u.s
quite tough talk from the uk uh and
impressive talk from europe but you know
not to the same degree by any stretch
because simply logistically it is
impossible to do so look it is a big big
big move but it does present threats to
the way that the uh that the west might
be able to stay united in its response
to peace what will you say that but the
u.s
gets no gas from russia and only seven
percent of its oil and is a an energy
exporter as we heard from joe biden
today uh in britain the guardian is
reporting four percent of gas and eight
percent of oil comes from russia
although some more i think via european
markets and the eu sources about 40
percent of its gas from russia and 27 of
its oil as well so that is the big
impact uh the ft also going with this
markets rattled by push for russian
crude ban as refugee crisis mounts they
say and part of this is um shell too
isn't it olivia
a couple of days ago the ukrainian
foreign minister um tweeted that he'd
heard that shell had discreetly bought
some russian oil
one question to shell he said doesn't
russian oil smell ukrainian blood for
you and it's very emotive isn't it this
the the pressure that's being put
um on individual companies we're seeing
a whole raft more of companies now
pulling out and closing their their
operations in russia
it's very interesting yeah and shell has
obviously reacted very quickly to that
but then we've also got which i think we
might be talking about in more detail
later but mcdonald's pulling out of
russia and now there are going to be all
sorts of corporates who who who feel the
need to to follow suit so i think we
were expecting as a raft of sanctions
from government but i think what we
weren't quite expecting was this
completely separate independent response
response from corporates which actually
may have more of an effect than those
government sanctions if you think of the
people in russia living their ordinary
lives um
not having the mcdonald's down the road
will will have a big effect um and you
could see putin being
generally kind of undermined
fundamentally undermined by by ordinary
russians who are really feeling the
pinch not necessarily from western
governments but from western companies
putting on their own sanctions in effect
absolutely coca-cola ii pepsico thinking
about it we might as well talk about
that now while we're on it uh it's in
it's in the financial times isn't it um
and the difficulty really is how
companies decide to continue to operate
in russia given the the groundswell of
opinion about this ian
yeah i mean this is i don't think this
is happening because companies have
suddenly found their moral core they're
taking serious losses i mean you look at
what bp and shelter these are serious
serious losses mcdonald's the same den
you know just is holding out at the
moment i don't know how much longer it
will be able to hold out they're doing
this because the public are putting
pressure on them like i mean it's hard
to think of another period where we've
seen such effective public pressure just
this pent-up outrage this appalled moral
sense of what russia has done making
changes and that's been the way all the
way through i mean you look at the
reaction in sport when it comes to fifa
look at the reaction with eurovision
these guys are not making these
decisions because they want to they're
doing it because they're scared of the
consequences of not making the decision
and it has a significant impact i mean
we we talk it down as if it's smallest
of its culture a lot of the time i mean
i agree i don't think it's a small thing
at all i think it's a major major deal
for people if you can't get apple if you
can't get netflix if you can't get
mcdonald's the things that the russian
middle class is like that make life
luxurious and enjoyable are the same
things that the british middle class is
like and you take that away from them
and suddenly you get a more tense and
more difficult and more volatile
political situation than you had
beforehand
well 847 restaurants in russia going
most of which a company owned
starbucks is also suspending all
business activity in russia including
shipment of its products and cafes run
by license unilever too i mean we've
talked before about you know russia
effectively being cancelled is that is
that what this appears and and if so
you know what what does it leave russia
as after all of this olivia
i i think the sort of difficulty is yes
it definitely does feel as though
russia's being being canceled or or
sanctioned or or however you want to put
it but
i think the question is whether the
russian people see it as an attack from
putin whether they see it as putin's
fault whether they see western countries
as intervening here because their
president has gone mad and they start to
turn against putin or whether they see
it is the west is ganging up on russia
is bullying russia
and it sort of reawakens anti-western
sentiment in russia i think mcdonald's
is a particularly interesting case
because as the ft points out on its
front page mcdonald's in russia was a
was a big post-soviet symbol sort of
sign of consumerist capitalist uh you
know
western ideals coming into russia and
with that gone it it it's quite a big
symbol so i think just the question is
now how russia how the russian people
respond to it whose fault do they see it
as will they turn against their
president or will they just blame the
west
uh let's move on to uh the refugee
crisis and finally a humanitarian
corridor worked out of the uh the city
of sumi um critically uh many foreign
students had been trapped at
universities in sumi including indian
and chinese students
critical you might think for
you know a weathervane of how they feel
about this to president putin um so 5000
managed to escape sumi 1700 foreign
students um is it right to be cynical
about that do you think that the the
foreign students were prioritized do you
think by russia ian
we don't have a basis to come to that
sort of conclusion at the moment we
should also add that across ukraine
foreign students especially people that
aren't white especially for people from
indian subcontinent especially black
people who have suffered some quite
appalling acts of racism in ukraine
often on the border with poland and it's
been a difficult tough time for them at
the moment at the moment what we mostly
think is anyone that can get out that
manages to get out that is a good thing
and our only hope really should be that
britain was doing a better job and
pulling its weight and helping them and
not leaving it to predominantly eastern
europeans and some other western
european states well some reports
tonight that there will be coaches at
calais to take people to some of these
areas where you need to do this
biometric testing to get to
the uk so we wait and watch that uh the
metro again talking about the refugee
crisis set to outpace the fall of
afghanistan uh more than two million
ukrainians have now fled the the russian
invasion two million there as you can
see without a home i mean this is an
extraordinary enormous job isn't it for
all those neighbors of ukraine to to now
deal with and accommodate these uh these
refugees olivia
absolutely and what britain's role in
this crisis is is going to come under a
a big spotlight now and that there's a
legitimate argument i think in the uk
that quite a lot of ukrainians want to
be housed in neighbouring countries
because they're not migrants they're
refugees they want to sit out this
crisis and go home as soon as it's safe
for them to do so but on the other hand
it does sort of feel as though the uk
government to to be asking refugees for
the eight forms of of identification or
whatever it is uh when they come into
the uk seems absolutely absurd and it
does seem to speak of a home office in a
very precarious situation um it was
quite clear we did have a lot of
preparation for this to happen we knew
that there were russian troops gathering
on the border so why the uk hasn't
updated its its refugee housing program
does seem to be quite strange and i
think we are going to come under a lot
more uh
forensic analysis on that over the
coming weeks
olivia utley and ian dunt thank you both
very much indeed
for now they'll be back at 11 for more
news to the weather though now